مارك أريد تشغيل مقطع من أجلك من
الجنود الروس الذين تم حشدهم حديثًا والذين هم
بالفعل في الخطوط الأمامية ، استمع إلى
هذه
[الموسيقى]
لدينا هذا القرف للتدريب
يعرف نوع المنزل الذي نحن فيه ثلاث
خراطيش خارقة للدروع.
أنت في svatov يا رفاق ،
ما منطقة lujansk التي تم
تعبئتها ، لا يتعين علينا أن نكون هنا
طوال 11 يومًا من وقت انتشارنا ،
لقد غادرنا موسكو قبل 11 يومًا ، كم
مرة أطلقت فيها بالفعل مرة واحدة ثلاث
خراطيش رصاصة
شكرًا لك على ذلك  لاحظ أن هذا كان تدريبهم بالكامل
، يقول هناك إنهم أطلقوا
مرة واحدة ثلاث خراطيش رصاصة
وكان هذا هو مدى التدريب ، ومن
الجدير بالذكر أن المدينة التي
سمعناها للتو يذكر فاتوف كما قلته ،
وهو حجر الزاوية في أي جهد روسي مستقبلي
لتأمين استعادة لوهانسك ،
فما الذي يقوله لك أنه سيكون
لديهم مجندين مثل هذا في تلك المدينة ،
نعم لقد رأيت هذا الفيديو اليوم ، آه في
الواقع هناك نحاول الآن
تحديد الموقع الجغرافي بالضبط قريبًا
لأنه إذا أخذت  بإلقاء نظرة على هذا الفيديو ،
قد لا تكون ورقة على الحائط وبقيت هذه
الورقة من القوات الأوكرانية
التي بقيت هناك في نفس
المبنى في عام 2021 ، لذا أعتقد أنه من المحتمل
أن يكون الجيش الأوكراني قادرًا على
تحديد الموقع الجغرافي لهذا المكان بالنسبة للتدريب
أه نعم هذا  مشكلة شائعة جدًا كان هذا
الرجل محظوظًا في الواقع لأنه تم إحضاره إلى
ميدان الرماية وكان قادرًا على
تصوير ثلاث أغطية للرصاص في نفس
الوقت نعلم أن الكثير من المجندين
الذين تم حشدهم من قبل هؤلاء الرجال الروس
لم يتم حشدهم حتى على هذا النحو.  تم
نقلهم للتو إلى مكاتب التسجيل العسكرية الخاصة بهم ،
ثم يكون لديهم أه ذات يوم في
بعض المراكز الإقليمية ثم
يتم إحضارهم للتو إلى الحدود وإرسالهم إلى
أوكرانيا ، لذا نعم ، يمثل نقص التدريب
مشكلة أخرى